[Applause]
uh
there's something i need to come clean
about i've been keeping this in for
for far too long now
i suck at tick and i've been asked
to do a tech review i'm scared shitless
this is me doing possibly the world's
worst
tech review ever in history
ever it all started with this not so
terrifying looking box carrying a horror
stricken task
which or rather what is the sponsor of
this video the razer blade 15 in
collaboration with nvidia and this is me
half willingly signing the proof of
acceptance of this box which i
just tossed in the pile of the deal with
later stuff
but as time passed i was haunted by
opening it
something unexplainable was playing a
sick mind game with me i don't want to
see what's happening to me
oh boy
[Music]
i've been here before it was two years
ago in new york city where i couldn't
even finish
a tech review intro sequence today's the
day
tech review tech review tech review did
you shoot a proper intro yet for tech
review tuesday
hey did you finish the uh tech tuesday
intro there's no excuse not to finish
she's gonna clearly traumatize me
somehow because i mean look at me
just tweaking out so time to make this
take video
[Music]
i [ __ ] can't do anything tech proper
let's go look at this in a cleaner
environment
at first glance the new specs are an on
switch cool colorful
keyboard lights many holes
[Music]
a cool logo i mean
look at my reaction i'm cortana
and i'm here to help [ __ ] you know okay
enough
intro how do i turn you off united state
how'd i get back to the point
is she get you connected to a network
shut up
um i'm gonna call him a friend
he has devoted his life to being a d.i.t
which stands for digital imaging
technician chief
what are you doing bro get it together
this is jurgen he's he knows tech and
stuff
is that it for you
my tech god
say stuff okay wi-fi
now type your credentials that's what i
was having my problem with
can't get rid of here choose yes who's
this
chick what do you think slogan popping
archer with the cool green light
quite like that speakers i really like
the lights on the keyboard changing
colors which is good
it's a 10th gen i7 which is just reading
off this
i could have told you all this [ __ ]
fantastic job done you can leave
awesome shot spirit for nothing
i'm joking i'm going to give the tech
guard aka jurgen
some time with this beast of the laptop
to come back with some actual valuable
is information sick i know pretty much
everything about it you know something
about it
everything so basically explore your
projects with a vibrant 4k oled
touchscreen display
showing accurate color which supports
100 dci p3 color space
and allows you to unleash your full
creative potential
nvidia has designed and created the rtx
2080 gpu with studio ready drivers in
the razer blade 15 laptop
which accelerates your workflow within
your creative tools like adobe and
blackmagic
so you can decode in real time and
encode up to 8k footage faster than
while any laptop i
have ever experienced in what world is
this gonna help me
i've only ever known how to make films
in one way
and that's through using the system that
i set into place
when i was 16 years old and i got my
first computer and i learned how to cut
by teaching myself by
writing and scribbling little notes on
the manual on
on the program that i was editing on and
for the art form itself there's
something in it that makes me feel as if
tech is gonna somehow come in and
destroy
the authenticity of the actual
filmmaking process
and i'm scared of technology like this
shut up bro
let me explain to you how this guy is
not going to take
that creativity away from you it's not
going to change your process it's only
going to streamline
all your work in one package just show
me
show me how it's going to make it i've
got a way to show you
the stress test
wow cool intro but what is that well
i've taken one of your forms duplicated
it
over onto two drives where we will test
your old system old
it's new well we're gonna test that
system versus the new razer blade 15.
so we're going to export these in a
side-by-side comparison
and i'm just going to show you how this
one is going to kick
your current computer's arse so together
now
we're doing file then you teach me how
to
export a [ __ ] phone yeah okay you can
kind of send yeah
cool three two one
okay head start okay okay
[Music]
just hangs at 99.
and you oh okay i mean it was a good
race
dude i lost horribly
i can go home now we need to be at the
finish line
on
[Music]
done okay we both got to the end we did
we got today you beat me
[ __ ] you you let me down
in progress just
okay honestly i never thought these
words would come out of my mouth
i'm gonna be using this razer blade 15
for my rendering
why is my computer so loud it's still
making a noise it's not even doing
anything calm down
[Music]
okay you won you convinced me
i'm sold on the razorblade 15 and i
think that
for any creative who has to bring out
okay we get it yeah and on that note
don't forget
you're awesome brew and i'll be seeing
you sooner than you think because
i'm fast now
she was kind of heavy taking
and i was already